let's get into audience questions for
the week first question hey David
isn't it time to end daylight savings
time once and for all this is an
interesting question we talk about it
every year when we do the time change in
the fall and then in the spring one
thing is that I'm gonna address the
question but usually when people talk
about should we end daylight savings
time very often they actually mean
should we stay on daylight savings time
all year round in other words let's not
go back to standard time back and forth
so this goes back to 1918 and the idea
of daylight savings time to begin with
was to conserve energy the idea was if
in the winter when you wake up it's dark
you're going to use more energy you are
going to it's going to be colder because
the Sun is not yet up at all so you're
gonna use more heat you're gonna use
more lights so on and so forth in
reality I believe that going that ending
daylight savings time causes more
problems than it probably solves so the
energy savings number one are completely
unproven the light savings when you
consider that light bulbs particularly
as we switch to the more
energy-efficient ones are not actually
responsible for that much of all energy
usage can be outweighed by AC usage or
using more heat when people are home and
it is already darker out for example in
some places it really depends where you
live because the United States has so
many different climates and then in
addition to that you do have to account
for the number of car accidents that
take place for two reasons one is just
the switch is a sort of jet lag it's
only an hour but every time you move
forward and back you either have people
staying up an extra hour on Saturday
night because they know that they're
getting that hour back for free so to
speak to sleep that can increase car
accidents lead to people having one more
drink before driving home and then in
general when you move driving at night
when you have more driving at night as a
result of the fact that we're moving the
clocks so that it's the Sun comes up an
hour earlier but
sunsets an hour earlier you do have more
people driving home in the dark and that
would correlate with an increased number
of car accidents so the the benefit of
the benefits that daylight savings times
end is supposed to bring are
questionable at best and possibly
completely counterproductive in reality
so there are people who talk about
canceled daylight savings time I
actually think what we want to cancel is
the switching back and forth and I would
say let's let's make it permanent let's
make daylight savings time permanent the
way to do it is probably going to come
federally so States and some states do
opt out of changing time the way that
most states do I think air part or all
of Arizona part or all of Indiana do
this and of course individual states can
do that but I think really the way to do
this is the federal government should
just say we're not going to move the
clocks forward and back anymore we are
going to just stay my preference would
be on daylight savings time all the time
and then states and time zones would
follow there there isn't one other idea
which is let's reduce the number of time
zones and since it's not really the
question I don't want to get into the
details of how that you might think well
ok that might make it easier so that
there aren't as many hours separating
the East Coast and the west coast but
how does that relate to the question of
the changing of the clocks in daylight
savings time versus Standard Time that's
a story for another day but that is
another idea that that people sometimes
present so I am an advocate of ending
the time switching but I don't want to
end daylight savings time I want to make
daylight savings time permanent I really
don't care if when I get up in the
morning it's still sort of dark or
depending on what time you get out
completely dark I would love that extra
hour of sunlight and I would actually
argue that the health benefits of that
people are way more likely to go to the
gym after work or to do something social
after work if it's not pitch black at
4:45 in the middle of December in
Massachusetts and so I think that that's
the direction we should go